your entire 20s is supposed to be grunt
work men know this they know this they
know they go into an industry and the
older guys are going to kind of bully
them a bit and they know it and they get
over it you know what's so crazy I used
to in this horrible oppressive
patriarchy or sometimes the man made fun
of me it was so horrible I worked around
plumbers right and I would go teach how
to like you I sold Plumbing products and
literally I would go to these schools
and the way the men would bully each
other was meaner than any man has talked
to me in my life they were so mean and I
was like oh my like they were calling
this one guy fat this one guy ugly this
one guy's stupid like they whatever
insult you want to say it was so mean
and they just got on with it they didn't
to HR they just went and worked
did their job